and I never would do this by said to the
cop I go I don't care but it's kind of a
pain in the ass that I gotta walk
through there and it's literally just
littered with dudes coupling up in there
common you're gonna hate oh don't get me
started don't get me started I was like
man that's just a commonplace - [ __ ]
yes it's always been a gay old zoo I was
in Utah uh and I was in the bathroom in
the stall and dude did this with his
foot
no yeah - down vd gives you a triple tap
I thought man he's looking to [ __ ] how
strive rushed out of there yeah but I
always thought these three taps like is
this a murder thing is this a dicksuck
thing that's how they caught that
congressman that Senator in the airport
and he had been responsible for anti-gay
legislation what a surprise hypocrite
yeah I have nothing dude that I like I
don't know what happened it was like
this it's very but it's like you know
you're like this it's over here yeah put
my mouth to the mic no yeah yeah I don't
know why did you bring him off your
Heights in your legs and you got a very
short torso you're built like a frog
you're Billa humans I've had so much
conversation and critic criticism why
would you criticize a war what are you
what are you fighting we can't even give
a guest of water listen what is your
problem
oh yeah like you're mad because what's
up brother because why you man are we
recording are we are we live
well I'm sad and I feel like you're
upset cuz they took the guest of the
year and then I never met this
[ __ ] I don't know anything about
the other one that [ __ ] belt that
he's walking around he got that [ __ ]
online you're right he ain't the guest
of the [ __ ] year Theo von and you're
[ __ ] goofy haircut
it's a mullet mullet yeah why don't you
get a real haircut like everybody else
will see how [ __ ] funny what he'd
know cuz he's talked to me me is he's
talking to me talking a lot of [ __ ] this
[ __ ] guy he doesn't know what's going
here's an idea you have a stone wash
gene hat on well it's gray remember that
Stone wash I know I know I know but you
have a shirt for your body yes and it's
it's many paths but you know that ain't
[ __ ] what I can't tell what the no
what did you draw that ex-fighter yours
I work for a Showtime and now Showtime
boxing your I can't tell what the [ __ ]
that is do you know what that is Brian
yeah who drew that knows what it is
daddy who's that is that who knows that
right doesn't know I do I'll tell you
it's a very strong I'm not gonna say who
it is I guarantee I can't tell that's
Roberto Duran Duran it looks like Manny
Pacquiao but but but every boxer has
that picture anyway scare back to this
clean anymore I'm stressful before I get
to your stone wash Jean hat please do
Theo Vaughn alley cat later talking a
lot of [ __ ] a ton of [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ]
with your [ __ ] mullet and your your
your your belt that you ordered online
that belt weighs about 1.1 pounds that
ain't got no weight now it's real gold
it ain't real gold you don't gotta throw
yourself as the the guest of the year
and and and you know what I always come
around this time where we're in late
October yeah well season you let
everybody do their thing and now you
come in and I know you know what I do I
take that big dick out and I lay it on
the table no job respect to what a tame
cat cat that big white bread meat I put
on the table I come what's the Asian
dudes name Asia yeah
chin no you're the comic Bobby Lee he
was [ __ ] he's he's a guest early like
Nick Kroll as a beast Nick Swardson
please Nick Kroll records Oh a dude this
is not a competition giant dick and he
goes do you like to be dominated I was
like if you listen to the podcast to
know that I'm not into guys but I mean
well no if he does look like a guy's
yeah don't assume you but I but I was
like oh you rats on that date Oh chin
Jay had your back when me and Brian were
making funny for the air drop but he's
like who don't have your drop on I'm
like Lena Bryant Oh Jay goes everyone in
like in his business on zero drop on you
know Jason you know the impossible head
he's in this impossible sweaty head
shout out to Jason he's my I I sh4
impossible sweaty head yeah he's just
sweats like in the middle of the winter
like it you know it's terrible like the
worst sweat you've ever seen he comes
out of the sauna you're like Jesus
Christ man anyways he anyway
he has his ear drop on he said people do
it all the time on the subway in New
York and people just drop dick pics now
you say you have no and he goes it's one
of the fun things to do just sit on the
subway and click accept and get dick
pics and guys [ __ ] girls he goes it's
awesome why why why my ear drops on your
ear drops on you just pick it up off of
people's phones random people it's a you
know Larry the [ __ ] winds a problem
course you have naked pictures of
yourself on your phone only if you do it
though all if you want to jump you know
to them they do it to you they'll see
Brian's phones nearby they'll drop a
picture and you there's always a
previously there's no way you can't see
the bring it except then you've got this
fat [ __ ] and your phone that's great
hilarious I don't know who's like you
know you would baby I bet some hot girls
like out there freak and you're like
whose is this yeah career drop this yes
we've been through this rap who's the
white guy behind them real Guardian
bozos have you played ball hey would you
swallow a seal you think you'd beat me
in a one-on-one I would get rap
no I think you think you'd be me
one-on-one basketball thing rapper aren
t it no you don't play basketball well
dude how do you shoot let me see I you
should have kicked off just let me see
you like that's right let me shoot me
yeah I hit 13 never wrong your form all
right he's got a stand up
what okay let's let's see yours I'm like
this let me see I can already tell you
can't shoot like I don't need to shoot
on you I'll Drive in the you'll score a
point I'm gonna by default get this
right here and you're we're playing
piston rules we go with me like a
vitamin for playing horribly [ __ ] we
play with money on this [ __ ] right
Bieber
I will dunk on you put my nuts and
Duncan yeah I can
hello can't dunk [ __ ] on from pushing 40
both you figure 40 years old huh [ __ ]
you gonna dunk
Joel you 6-1 are you six - now he's
around your [ __ ] life no no listen
mean he said he's a much better athlete
than you stronger and much fans oh [ __ ]
but dialysis but I get your technique
when it comes yeah and I think because
yo yo yo you'll be able to shock him and
you'll be able to you'll be able to hit
the problem is he'll get in your kitchen
because you're you're a hysteric yeah
you won't get a mic nobody know what I
mean is your hysterics
and so you'll go you'll start to freak
out and you'll panic so then you're so
rapid you have a typical body I am
Rapoport stereo podcast worldwide
phenomenon yeah baby typical just got
picked up for season three and then what
and then three on three basketball
I mean and I mean what the [ __ ] else do
I I mean how much can I do that's what
I'm saying any movies or there's
something I might do I don't know how
about I I was at Saltonstall yesterday
and you know they have their are they
have like their special flavors in
October we have human finger ice cream
I wish fingernails no but they have
ground-up bugs grasshoppers and
mealworms chocolate-covered come on like
a person ice cream they also have pig's
blood ice cream what and then they had
another one that's called real pigs bug
now yeah come on
type in salt & straw yeah yeah
gelatinous big block that's pig's blood
you like blood it's called Dracula some
like coagulated blood yeah oh no that's
why that's on the weekend the course
Nauticus runny
do you like coagulated blood a union he
likes african-american he was related
blood
dim sum yeah he cubed bloody with tripe
that's it's amazing not in amazing I
don't drink I feel sick
well I can't need this I can't I can't
eat ice cream day I got there cherry and
smoked bone marrow ice cream and I even
bone marrow makes me feel sick no you uh
it's just go to all don't go images
there it goes creepy crawlers critters
salt & straw blood and bug ice cream
scroll down you can't tell right go up
chin cuz that's where the description I
think yeah single grasshopper and then
they have one with the blood is yeah but
they have one called candy topia and
it's butterscotch ice cream with Twix
Snickers and Reese's in it it will
change your [ __ ] life its I've ever
had in my life
the only a screen I've liked better from
them is they had a Lucky Charms ice
cream where's all just marshmallows from
Lucky Charms and vanilla ice cream
really my son does really nice came by
took him there and he went nuts on it
track his blood pudding there it is mmm
[ __ ] click on that bro let me educate
you can't tell how I read that ice
creams really crafted for this year's
Halloween thrill-seekers no Hannah
no-holds-barred this is the most
inducting we measured into real blood
pudding with a hint of chicken liver and
one star on an ice cream laboratory and
they get it from my fruit somewhere in
the blood to pay it's pig's blood
[ __ ] but you like eating it I'm not
trying
Joella tried the bugs ones I'll try the
bugs no problem no not me but blood see
this this is amazing
that's [ __ ] damn blood that's blood
stomach lining right there that's tried
mm-hmm out of all the shitty chin you
need that you got a taste in nothing
Julia I've never tried it
liar that looks like dog food ever tried
that looks like just like dog food I'm
sure I ate that stuff when I was in
China but I ate a bunch of stuff like
that where I was like what is this
nope if it's slimy and squared I don't
eat it we can't talk about our boys but
are you a vampire like you
outside right oh is that why I sleep
with you block but you boy you played a
lot of ball outside I mean you're on the
bench but you played you were out there
what I don't brain what you saw Matt run
tommy run to me you quietly impressed my
smile and we go grab a coffee while we
talk in beer I wanted to bring you a we
go suck the boys off while we talking
hey hey
wrap em bieed let's get it dude I
couldn't I couldn't be more excited for
the season what are you what are you are
you you jazz person for real no I was
just in Utah the Jazz are [ __ ]
janitor don't Jonathan Mitchell's
graty's dick you see I could teamed him
you're in the West it's I think the
sleepers are them and nuggets and
Dallas's listen
but the Nuggets their backcourt and then
the Joker
yup that perfect triple-double there
there good I mean Steph Curry last night
was blatantly disrespectful rude
[ __ ] on everybody he plays for the
wars Brian no no I know the boys know
why don't you go get me a [ __ ] almond
milk lot yeah
yeah man good for nothing me until you
guys are making me up bein a male right
now I'm into sports
I know Stefan Carl's Steph Curry went
off gold state off see that it's it's
almost unfair how good they're when you
see my back ripple and I pull myself up
like a champ like a champ thirty times
fast while talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a Gish it's a gift it's a gift